il est l'un des plus importants
sculpteur français considéré comme un
des pères de la sculpture moderne
cette exposition d'auguste rodin
regroupe différents types d'oeuvres le
musée rodin à apprêter quinze sculptures
et 25 photos d'époque se mêlant à ça le
travail d'emmanuel berry qui a mis en
lumière à sa façon les oeuvres de rodin
l'intérêt aujourd'hui était de présenter
dans le cadre du centenaire de la mort
de rodin ses photos dans leur contexte
de création au milieu des sculptures de
rodin et des photos à partir desquels il
a travaillé pour continuer cette
tradition
alors cette exposition est évidemment un
grand événement pour nous quinze
sculptures de rodin cet historique on en
a jamais eu autant
emmanuel berry a eu un accès privilégié
à l'atelier du sculpteur à meudon
un travail de longue haleine qui a duré
un an
il a utilisé des techniques
photographiques en noir et blanc et en
argentique à la lumière naturelle
la sculpture parle d'elle-même et se
révèle par sa sensibilité et un regard
plus contemporain il met en relief en
perspective pour aller à l'essence même
de l'oeuvre de rodin moi dans mon
processus
j'ai besoin déjà d'anticiper l'image
mentale et ensuite à tout un processus
de fabrication et je travaille dans la
lenteur j'ai besoin de cette lenteur là
pour me retrouver pour mieux comprendre
pour mieux filtrer essayer d'avoir le 1
juin qui va être plus précis une sorte
de nectar
rodin sous l'oeil du photographe
emmanuel berry c'est à découvrir
jusqu'au 15 avril au musée des
beaux-arts d'orléans
[Musique]